all right my talk of the table is about
another singer a grammy-winning singer
songwriter
alessia cara all you have to do
hit stay featuring dj zed and today
we're premiering the 25 year old's
dramatic new music video for
shapeshifter one of two new singles from
her upcoming third album
in an interview you'll see only on cbs
this morning cara says her song
sweet dreams sweet dream and
shapeshifter
represent two different sides the
helplessness she's felt
and the light she's found all in the
past year
is it too much to ask for a sweet dream
in her new song sweet dream alessia cara
sings about the insomnia that plagued
her during the pandemic
when anxiety attacks she thought she'd
conquered
came back with a vengeance suddenly
it just completely boiled over and i was
having panic attacks like for hours on
end every single day
i think if you ignore your body and your
mind long enough they force you to
listen to them you know
that must have been a little frightening
it was extremely frightening there's
something
in like anxiety terms called
derealization which is basically where
your mind
detaches from the rest of you and it
feels like you're living in a dream at
all times like i would look at my hands
and look in the mirror and and freak out
because i didn't
feel like i was connected to them yeah
it felt like i was looking at someone
else's
hands and face it was the most
terrifying thing that i think has ever
happened to me and i didn't know what
was going on
with therapy and medication cara says
she was able to turn the corner there
was music for you in this whole process
it was kind of at the forefront for me
it was my way of purging a lot of those
feelings and getting things out of my
system
there's one song on this record that you
wrote in a very specific house
very exciting shapeshifter was written
in the miami home of producer
salaam raimi where the late amy
winehouse
worked on her landmark album back to
black
the tree in his backyard is a tree she
wrote tears dry on
on their own under you know so it felt
so full circle for me
what did amy winehouse's music mean to
you it meant so much
you know all the like pop divas were
wonderful and great but i didn't i
didn't see myself in them because i
couldn't sing like them
i didn't really look like them and amy
you know like in her rehab video she had
like big curly hair
i really just saw myself in a lot of her
words and
you know in the way that she's saying
and maybe there was a place for you then
yeah exactly yeah she really like was
one of the first artists that taught me
that you can still touch people with
you know simplicity six years ago
cara broke through with her debut single
here
and in 2018 and the grammy goes too she
won the best new artist grammy
that's your card did you enjoy it at the
time
yes and no i think all my dreams were
coming through which was wonderful i had
like stars in my eyes i had you know so
doughy-eyed about the whole thing but
on the other end i think there's a lot
of pressure for someone
really young looking back i wish i had
stayed more present i wish i wasn't so
scared
her song scars to your beautiful became
an
anthem for outsiders
and part of your whole i mean i don't
want to say image
but i mean it was sort of that you
didn't have an image you know
yeah exactly you know the box you get
put into is that you don't have a box
you're still being put in a box you know
what i mean it's like a weird paradox
have you missed being out on the road um
i have actually yeah i think it's one of
those things that you
kind of take for granted when you do it
so often now the world is opening up
again
and in new york this week so was economy
candy
where the toronto-based singer went
looking for some canadian
candy oh my god coffee crisps this
is legendary i'm gonna go for these
okay i'm very excited about the harry
potter you got a lot
i got this full peanut
we did good all right thank you thank
you i actually don't have my wallet i
got you sorry
i'll get you back life
is now looking sweeter for alessia cara
with her new album on the way when you
listen to it now what do you hear
i think i can now look at those moments
in hindsight and realize how hopeful
it actually is because i'm not there
anymore and
it's nice to like look over your
shoulder and see that you've you know
come you've traveled somewhere yeah
you've gone somewhere you know so
it feels very hopeful now it's
interesting because she said
she said medication played a huge role
in and i want to get this right she said
i was terrified of medication until only
this year it's so
stigmatized i was scared to do it and
until i realized i needed it
she said it made an enormous difference
in her life i was struck guys when she
said
i wish i hadn't been so scared during
that time because she was here with her
dad
back in the day because when you see her
on stage she's so confident she's so
vibrant you don't have any
idea about what's going on behind the
scenes i love yours she's 19 years old
and she's not someone who's ever wanted
attention
yeah that's not what she's in it for and
so i think it was all very overwhelming
in so many ways
when can we get to new music i'm like i
don't know now we don't have a date yet
but those two songs are out and she said
it's
it's like a it's like an audible photo a
before and after photo of her brain
i'm gonna get it